Boris Palmer hat gerade das Stichwort
genannt Auszeit sie haben eine Auszeit
genommen sagten sie gerade wie lang die
war nicht lang vier Wochen den ganzen
weil
was passiert ist was hat dazu geführt
lasst es mich mal so sagen ich war für
mich an dem toten Punkt also ich habe
nach dem echten Shitstorm jetzt einen
gehabt der war auch für mich persönlich
so schlimm dass ich gesagt habe ich muss
jetzt irgendwie mal raus aus dieser
Mühle ich schaffe das auch nicht mehr
das wird mich und was konkret passiert
ist aus meiner Sicht wie wir schauen uns
die Szene gleich an der Umgebung aber
vielleicht sagen sie einmal kurz was dem
vorausgegangen ist was was war die Idee
sie waren in Frankfurt Frankfurt Main zu
einer Konferenz rund ums Thema Migration
wieder genau dieses Thema
Professoren Schröter genau
die ich eigentlich solidarisch
unterstützen wollte und stattdessen
jetzt ihre Konferenz verschossen hat was
mir sehr leid tut so und es geht jetzt
gar nicht um die Konferenz als solche
sondern es geht um das was dann vor der
Konferenz bereits passiert ist wenn sie
einmal kurz die Situation beschreiben
bevor wir die Bilder gleich sehen was
war das für eine Situation die sie da
reingelaufen sind sie kommen da an und
dann passiert was ich komme an und Wert
von der Gruppe begrüßt mit Gespräch Chor
es gibt kein Recht auf Nazipropaganda
und dann habe ich hingestellt und habe
mit skandiert weil das sehe ich genauso
es gibt natürlich kein Recht auf
Nazipropaganda das hat
erstaunlicherweise dazu geführt dass
kurz Ruhe eingekehrt ist dann dachte ich
nutze ich finde Diskussion weil ich
eigentlich das Gespräch für richtig
halte und es ist dann extrem schnell
eskaliert weil ich dann nach kurzer Zeit
auf diesen Sprechchor gehört habe ich
seinen Rassist dann habe ich gefragt
warum dann ging es um die Verwendung des
Wortes die sich heute nicht sagen werde
sie könnte es erklären ich mache das
nicht ich verbrennen wir daran nicht
mehr den Mund das ein Wort das Ende war
lass uns einfach sagen
ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht sehr
viele Leute wissen nicht was das in Wort
ist aber ist ihre Aufgabe als Moderator
ich sage es nicht so ich habe aber
diesen Leuten erklärt warum ich meine
dass da Kontext bestimmt über ein Wort
und nicht die simple Aussprache und
daraufhin baut sich einer von mir auf
mit dunkler Hautfarbe
und sagt sagen sie müssen ins Gesicht na
wie das gleiche wieder gesagt weil ich
finde dass das nicht davon abhängt
welche Hautfarbe man gegenüber hat und
dann ist richtig explodiert dann haben
sie mir aus der Gruppe so richtig mich
umbringen und mit lauten Nazi schreien
niederzuschreiben versucht und dann habe
ich gemerkt wie ich so richtig da Puls
rast was man machen soll und mich
versucht habe zu wehren und dann habe
ich einen objektivseitig ganz klar
völlig unzulässigen Vergleich mit dem
Judenstern gezogen und bin dann gegangen
und hat eigentlich nur gedacht
worden wir hören mal kurz rein
[Musik]
ich kann euch dazu auch eine Geschichte
erzählen
junge nein nein nein
sie ist raus nazis raus nazis raus
nazis raus ja ich will keine Nazis in
diesem Land
aber tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
raus fühlen Sie sich angesprochen
wenn man ein falsches Wort sagt ich war
für euch Nazi denk mal drüber nach
okay und dann war das Skandal perfekt
was ist danach passiert
direkt danach kam der Institutsdirektor
zu mir und sagte die jungen Leute seien
so im gekommen hängt seit ich hätte den
dunkelhäutigen Mann mit dem Wort der
sich nicht sagen werde persönlich
beleidigt
frei erfunden ich habe den nicht
beleidigt würde ich auch nie machen ich
würde nie einen Menschen so bezeichnen
wir haben über die Frage ob dieses Wort
ausgesprochen werden darf gestritten und
ich habe gesagt nur weil ich dieses Wort
auch ausspreche wenn der Kontext es
erlaubt dann bin ich deswegen kein Nazi
das will ich direkt danach passieren
dann hat die Konferenz stattgefunden und
am nächsten Morgen hat die Universität
eine Presseerklärung rausgegeben dass
ich den Holocaust relativiert hätte
mit dem Begriff Juden sterben was mich
erstmal total konstaniert hat aber ich
sage jetzt auch noch mal was die Auszeit
muss ja auch ein Ergebnis in der
mitteilen was mir da klar geworden ist
ich wusste vorher aber jetzt ist für
mich klar in Deutschland gibt es aus
grünem Grund eine große Linie man darf
egal wie keine Vergleiche dieser Art
machen weil es dann immer jemand gibt
der üble Absicht hat und wirklich
den Holocaust relativieren will die
nazikräuel relativieren will das war
nicht meine Absicht aber niemand kann
den Menschen reingucken und deswegen
haben wir diese rote Linie niemand macht
es finde ich richtig und man kannte
sehen wie das funktioniert wenn da
jemand wie gauland sagt das war ja nur
ein vogelschieß in der Geschichte die
Nazizeit und sich dann rausreden mit
ihrem meint es im Verhältnis 12000 ja
offensichtlich das was anderes gemeint
ist man will eigentlich sich irgendwie
wieder frei machen von dieser
historischen Schuld so das ist eine rote
Linie das war ein schwerer Fehler von
mir das darf mir nicht passieren und
dann mache ich auch gar nicht dran rum
ich erkläre ihn aber gerne wenn sie es
wollen wie es für mich dazu gekommen ich
will auch darüber habe ich nachgedacht
ja
das passieren und das hat ganz viel mit
meiner Familie Geschichte zu tun ich
muss ihn eigentlich von drei Gefängnis
Aufenthalten erzählen um das zu erklären
der erste war 1963 mein Vater deswegen
Nichtigkeiten auf dem Moment ins
Gefängnis gekommen wurde dort schwer
zusammengeschlagen von alten Nazis in
beamtenkostüm also
beamtenazis die wussten dass er wegen
seines jüdischen Vaters eine Strategie
Figur war und die wollten den fertig
machen und der hat sein Vater war das
uneheliche
uneheliche Kinder des jüdischen
jüdischen Vaters damit halb Jude für die
Nazis in der Schule wurde er Moses
gerufen nicht helmut hat ganz schwer
gekauft sein ganzes Leben lange hat sein
Vater nie kennengelernt weil der musste
im migrieren mit der ganzen Familie also
eine jüdische Geschichte er wollte
diesen jungen Leuten da in Frankfurt
gesagt wisst ja ihr werft bevor ich sein
Nazi das war jetzt nicht im Film meine
Vorfahren liegen seit 1700 irgendwas auf
dem jüdischen Friedhof in
Königsbach-Stein und da sind in den
90ern Neonazis gekommen am Hakenkreuze
drauf gemacht und diese Gräber
geschildert ihr sagt mir ich sein Nazi
und sie trotzdem weiter gemacht ich
spiele keine Rolle also er ist da schwer
misshandelt worden in dieser Zeit immer
und immer wieder erzählt Unrecht in
diesem Staat sich gegen dieses wenn man
Unrecht erlebt aufzulegen war sozusagen
die wichtigste Botschaft die mir als
Kind mitgegeben hat ich rechtfertige
mich jetzt nicht so ich erkläre wie ich
mich selber da in der Reflexion erlebt
habe der zweite Gefängnisaufenthalt
war 1979 da habe ich mein Vater besucht
er war wegen Beleidigung fünf Monate im
Knast im Hochsicherheitsgefängnis in
Stammheim die RAF sozusagen im anderen
Stockwerk und wir wollten den besuchen
dann würden wir untersucht gefilzt meine
Mutter und mein Bruder
bis auf die Unterhose meine Mutter
wollte den Brief reinschmuggeln ins
Gefängnis dann wurde der Besuch erstmal
in Frage gestellt und wir durften mein
Vater dann nur noch sehen dass wir den
Raum geführt worden Panzerglasscheibe in
der Mitte auf der einen Seite mein Vater
ein Beamter der alles mitschreib auf der
anderen Seite wir beiden ich war 7 Jahre
alt man oder fünf und die Begrüßung war
Hände auflegen an die Panzerglasscheibe
mehr war nicht drin dann persönlich im
Kontakt und subjektiv zu tiefst
ungerechte verurteilen wir ja damit
erlebt hat und der dritte
Gefängnisaufenthalt aber insgesamt
anderthalb Jahre im Gefängnis immer
wegen Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt
Beamtenbeleidigung etc der Vater halt
als Querulanten ist glaube ich als
Rebell für manche Ware ein Idol wir
haben einen kleinen Ausschnitt gefunden
der das mal klar macht welche Dimension
das hatte vielleicht zeigen
wer wer Helmut Palma wir schauen mal
kurz rein
mit blanke Wut reagiert Helmut Palmer
auf das Wahlergebnis von Pranger des
Haller Rathausplatzes giftet er gegen
die Anhänger seines siegreichen
Konkurrenten das Wahlergebnis ist für
den Obsthändler aus dem Remstal
manipuliert und er selbst fühlt sich
betrogen
stellt ein vor
stellt euch vor der Schwindel
verschwinde beginnt schon wieder da
dann geht der Schwindel schon von neuem
los ist auf Kritik reagiert Palma wütend
Polemik als Ersatz für Sachargumente und
deshalb sehen viele in ihm den starken
Mann den Volkstribun der sich der
Obrigkeit entgegen stellt doch seine
größte Stärke er kann lauter schreien
als alle anderen
die immer so nach innen gekehrt sind und
nach außen jeden links und rechts liegen
lassen jawohl
nach dem ersten Zorn über die Niederlage
ist Palma bald wieder der alte Tausende
von Anhängern feiern ihn als hätte er
gesiegt sein Führungsanspruch als einzig
aufrechter Demokrat wird von seinen Fans
messianisch hochgehalten
[Applaus]
warum ging es darum eine
Bürgermeisterwahl oder warum war die
Oberbürgermeisterwahl in Schwäbisch Hall
die hier fast gewonnen hätte wie oft ist
er angetreten zu einer Bürgermeister 250
Mal also 250 mal 250 meilenheit zu jeder
Polizist demokratische Veranstaltung
wenn man sagt das hat ja was trumpet ne
man sagt ihr habt mir die Wahl geklaut
50 Jahre später mag ich das jetzt so
interpretieren lassen aber ich glaube
man muss schon Zeit gebunden dann drauf
schauen ich verstehe das dass ein dass
irritiert und dass eines demokratische
Wahl also eine Frage der Hintergrund ist
kompliziert weil alle parteikandidaten
sich dann am Ende auf einen geeinigt
haben um ihn zu verhindern und das
meinte damit okay also im ersten
Jahrgang war weit vorne mit 41 %. dann
haben alle interessante Palmer muss man
verhindern das wäre ganz schlimm für die
Parteien aber das ist Demokratie
unabhängig gewählt wird und deshalb hat
okay also ich glaube mit Trump ist nicht
wirklich vergleichbar
das heißt ich ich sehe das ist ein
schöner was ich erlebt habe mit meinem
Vater natürlich anders ich habe mich
logischerweise stark mit dem
identifiziert und dieser dritte
Gefängnisaufenthalt macht es glaube ich
dann noch noch deutlicher wenn man weiß
wieder zustande kam mein Vater hat Bäume
am Straßenrad umgesetzt umgesägt um
gegen Bürokratie und Beamten Dummheit
würde er das ausgedrückt haben zu
demonstrieren weil die immer nach fünf
Jahren zu 90% kaputt waren muss wissen
ihr Vater gepflegt
baumwartung
hat gelernt in der Schweiz und hat sich
dann erregt dass norddeutsche
firmenausschreibungen gegangen zum
Baumpflege und der nie da waren und dann
an der Straße nach fünf Jahre die Bäume
kaputt waren
Geldverschwendung gesehen hat die
umgesagt und dann wurde im
strafbefehlern lassen hat geklagt ging
vor Gericht da hat er gewonnen weil die
totenbäume kein Wert mehr hatten und
dann konnte man auch nichts beschädigen
finde ich eigentlich einleuchtend aber
wurde trotzdem total 1000 € Geldstrafe
vorurteilt ja Baden-Württemberg hat ein
interessante Geschichte zu 1000 €
Geldstrafe verurteilt weil und das heißt
ich von erst später weil mich ein
Kollege dieses Beamten dann 10 Jahre
danach inform
keiner wirklich irgendwie behaupten
konnte dass er da mit den Holocaust
relativieren weil es war trotzdem sicher
nicht gut aber für mich geht es gar
nicht und das habe ich in dieser
Situation einfach verkannt so ist es
rückblickend in meiner Reflexion ist es
zu erklären dass ich diesen schweren
Fehler gemacht habe und da wir nochmal
eine Frage noch bevor ich bin sehr
gespannt was Frau bota und Eva Quadbeck
dazu sagen
noch mal einen Schritt zurück
in dieser Szene vorhin in Frankfurt der
Mann fordert sie auf das Wort zu sagen
ja sag's mir ins Gesicht
ja und sie machens warum das habe ich
nicht verstanden wir haben uns mal
darüber unterhalten und sie sagten das
war der Begriff der mir hängen geblieben
ist sie sagten ich hatte damals in dem
Moment das Gefühl ich das ist sowas wie
der will dass ich mich unterwerfe und
deswegen mache ich das ganz genau und
ich habe dann gedacht nein es ist doch
genau umgekehrt der hält die jetzt
sozusagen diese Provokation hin diese
Stöckchen hin
und ich meine mein Reflex wäre immer zu
sagen du glaubst doch nicht im Ernst
dass ich dir dass ich das jetzt tue auf
gar keinen Fall mache ich das weil ich
genau weiß was daraus werden kann aber
sie machen es und das ist doch die
Unterwerfung sie machen genau das was er
von ihnen möchte sie sagen es klüger als
ich es gemacht habe aber für mich hat
sie es anders angefühlt noch mal mein
Vater auf dem Haus meine elternlichen
Haus steht drauf eigenen Sinn und
Glauben lasse ich mir nicht glauben
jedes Buch das er unterschrieben hat mit
seiner Signatur hat er noch dazu
geschrieben nur die CDU ich weiß ja ich
gebe nicht nachher nicht wenn ich mich
im Recht fühle und es war nicht die
Situation wo ich mir ganz klar gesagt
hat ich unterwerfe mich nicht diesem
Zwang der mir vorschreiben kann was ich
sage das geht übrigens unter ich habe
das als Argumente ich lass mir von euch
nicht vorschreiben was ich sage und
diesen Impuls habe ich an der Stelle
nachgegeben ja sie haben rechts ihre
Reaktion der klüger gewesen
und das war der Grund für sehr sie haben
Therapie gemacht
gut Therapie würde ich es nicht nennen
also ich habe auch mich dann kurz
checken lassen ob Therapie jetzt die
richtige Reaktionsform wäre ich war
veröffentlich verstanden haben da ist
etwas in Ihnen und das wird ihn immer
wieder zum Verhängnis ja also diese
Impulse da so über zu regeln die habe
ich und die Frage die besser zu
kontrollieren hat sich mehr gestellt
aber die Gespräche die ich geführt habe
haben ziemlich sicher für mich ergeben
es geht nicht um eine krankhafte
Deformation so es geht wirklich darum
Techniken der Selbstbeherrschung zu
trainieren und da ist ein Coach der
richtige Ansprechpartner
wie schauen Sie auf das oder wie
bewerten sie das was sie da hören Frau
Quadbeck also erstmal Respekt dafür wenn
man mit über 50 Jahren noch mal so aus
einem Job auch aus der Öffentlichkeit
rausgeht auch das auch die
Öffentlichkeit hat ja dann auch Teil
daran und so ein Prozess des an sich
selber Arbeitens sich dem unterzieht
dann habe ich erstmal großen Respekt vor
auch die Fähigkeit sich so zu
reflektieren die hat nämlich längst
nicht jeder jeder hätte
dann wären wir sicherlich in vielen
Punkten weiter ich frage mich so Mensch
warum hat Herr Palma das nicht
eigentlich vor 20 Jahren gemacht ähm
vielleicht wäre er dann heute noch
Mitglied der Grünen und vielleicht wäre
er dann der Aspirant in
Baden-Württemberg Ministerpräsident zu
werden weil ich immer gedacht habe dass
er Palma schon ein sehr ja talentiert
hat Politiker ist und er den Tübingen ja
auch wirklich viel zu Wege gebracht und
dann habe ich eben auch immer wieder
Dinge in der Öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen
die mich dann auch total irritiert haben
und wo ich dann auch gedacht habe das
was sie jetzt beschrieben haben so
irgendwie klemmt da die Impulskontrolle
und
ja also das aber mir nötig das was sie
jetzt gerade gesagt haben total viel
Respekt ab weil es ja wenn man mal ganz
ehrlich auf sich selber schauen muss und
das ist immer schwer
vom Butter wie geht es Ihnen dabei ich
meine da sitzt jemand der unglaublich
polarisiert hat nein wir hatten hier
auch schon sehr sehr harte Gespräche
und um Diskussionen und da sitzt jemand
von dem ich immer wieder erlebe wird
auch beschrieben von auch von sehr
einflussreichen Spitzenpolitikern von
grünen Spitzenpolitikern vor allen
Dingen die sagen so schade da ist dieses
unglaubliche Talent aber auf der anderen
Seite macht er sich dann immer wieder
alles selbst kaputt ja ich glaube also
sie sagten sie hätten sie für einen
Coach entschieden eine Therapie zu
beginnen ist ist nicht schlimm ist also
im Gegenteil und und offenbar hat in
ihre Familie ein
großes Päckchen mitgegeben im Leben dass
mich nur an ihrer Geschichte so also ich
habe erstmal ganz viele Fragen das ist
auch eine unglaublich
volle und wendungsreiche Geschichte über
die ich auch noch nachdenken muss aber
es gibt da etwas was mich irritiert und
das ist dass sie so geschlossen ist und
sie erklärt jetzt was war und ich finde
sie kann vielleicht Ansätze bieten um
etwas zu erklären aber bei ihm klingt es
so als wenn sie dieses Mal zu weit
gegangen
und es wäre eben dieses
Bewusstsein für Unrecht einzustehen
etwas was bei den familiär weitergegeben
worden ist
aber das heißt ja dass das also dass sie
eigentlich immer im Recht waren und das
wage ich zu bezweifeln mir fehlt ein
bisschen die Ebene wo sie vielleicht die
Situation wo Menschen sich verletzt
fühlten wo sie Skandale ausgelöst haben
sicherlich einige übertrieben und die
Situation die wir eben gesehen haben an
der Universität die stehe ich mir
unglaublich belastend vor also so eine
kreischende Menge und man kommt nicht
dagegen an und sie versuchen es und
trotzdem gab es ja auch andere
Situationen wo sie auch dann noch drauf
behaart haben Recht zu haben als die
anderen ihn gespiegelt haben sie haben
hier meine persönlichen Grenzen
überschritten und diese Ebene fehlt mir
fühle also mich im Recht fühle das heißt
nicht dass sie im Recht bin das können
sie dich immer unbedingt das nehme ich
nicht für mich in Anspruch auch bei
meinem Vater habe ich so formuliert wenn
er der Meinung war dass da Unrecht
geschieht und da war ich schon als Sohn
nicht immer seiner Meinung war auf da
der Meinung hat mein Vater gesagt also
ich glaube da bist du jetzt eigentlich
im Unrecht ja hat er nie akzeptiert und
er sich zu sein aber gebe ich ihn völlig
recht es ging ja nur darum dass
Mechanismus zu beschreiben die Situation
im Moment ist in zwei Minuten und wenn
ich selber das Gefühl hat ja vollkommen
zu Unrecht fertig gemacht wird sondern
greifenden Menge die mir keine Chance
lässt oder dann so umringt und dann als
Nazi angeschrien zu werden mit meiner
Familie Geschichte das wollte ich
irgendwie beschreiben das ist in dieser
Situation einfach dann sondern
Kessel und dann fliegt er irgendwann weg
ja und dann passiert sowas
das ist eine emotionale Zumutung
zweifelsohne aber wenn sie jetzt
zurückgehen und vielleicht die anderen
Ereignisse anschauen
manchmal vielleicht auch das Bedürfnis
sich bei den Menschen die sie mir gesagt
auf die Füße getreten sind zu
entschuldigen
also wenn ich den Eindruck habe dass das
tatsächlich der Fall ist gerne und habe
ja auch schon gemacht
wenn ich den Eindruck habe die
Verletzung wird nur instrumentiell
vorgetäuscht um damit Macht über andere
auszuüben tue ich es nicht und ich
glaube dass genau das ist Problem dieser
Kultur der Kränkung und Verletzung ist
die wir in unserer Diskurskultur immer
stärker pflegen dass man sich nicht mehr
auf das Argument stützt sondern es noch
viel stärkere Argumente der eigenen
Verletzung präsentiert und dann erwartet
dass der andere jetzt aber nichts mehr
dagegen sagen darf und das halte ich für
hochproblematisch da würde ich eher mit
und Alt Bundespräsident argumentieren
deshalb kränkungsverschonung ist keine
legitime Förderung wir müssen Menschen
stärken dass sie Kränkungen aushalten
können weil Kränkungen sind unvermeidbar
im Zusammenleben zwischen Menschen und
deswegen bin ich da zurückhaltend
wirklich das oft erlebt habe dass es nur
ein vorgetäuscht das argumenische oder
Anwälte von Leuten die sich gar nicht
äußern behaupten jemand anders sei
verletzt worden auch das sind so Dinge
würde mich sehr schwer aber echte
Verletzung ich dafür zu entschuldigen
dass ich ja